hi this video is about inferential
statistics at the beginning we'll go
through what inferential statistics is
and then I will explain the six key
components to you let's start with the
first question what is inferential
statistics inferential statistics allows
us to make conclusions or inferences
about a population based on the data
from a sample what is the population and
what is the sample the population is the
whole group we're interested in if you
want to study the height of all adults
in the United States that the population
would be all adults in the United States
the sample is a smaller group we
actually study chosen from the
population for example 150 adults were
selected from the United States and now
we want to use the sample to make a
statement about the population and here
are the six steps how to do that number
one hypothesis first of course we need a
statement a hypotheses that we want to
test for example we want to know whether
a drug will have a positive effect on
blood pressure in people with high blood
pressure but what's next in our
hypothesis we have stated that we would
like to study people with high blood
pressure so our population is all people
with high blood pressure in for example
the US now we want to use this sample
from that population to make a statement
about the whole population but how do we
do that for this we need a hypothesis
test hypothesis testing is a method for
testing a claim about a parameter in a
population using data measured in a
sample great that's exactly what we need
there are many different hypothesis
tests at the end of this video I will
give you a guide to help you find the
right test but how does a hypothesis
test work when we conduct a hypothesis
test we start with a research hypothesis
also called alternative hypothesis this
is the hypothesis we are trying to find
evidence for in our case that drug has
an effect on blood pressure but we
cannot test this hypothesis directly
with the classical hypothesis test so we
test the opposite hypothesis that the
drug has no effect so we first assume
that the drag has no effect in the
population if we now take a random
sample and it turns out that the drag
has a large effect in the sample then we
can ask How likely it is to draw such a
sample or one that deviates even more if
the drag actually has no effect if this
probability is very low we can ask
ourselves maybe the drag has an effect
in the population and we may have enough
evidence to reject the null hypothesis
that the drug has no effect and it is
this probability that is called the P
value let's summarize this in three
simple steps number one the null
hypothesis states that there is no
difference in the population number two
the hypothesis test calculates how much
the sample deviates from the null
hypothesis number three the P value
indicates the probability of getting a
sample that deviates as much or more
than our sample under the assumption
that the null hypothesis is true but at
what point is the P value small enough
for us to reject the N hypothesis this
brings us to the next Point statistical
sign significance if the P value is less
than a predetermined threshold often
0.05 the result is considered
statistically significant meaning that
the result is unlikely to have occurred
by chance alone and that we have enough
evidence to reject the null hypothesis
therefore a small P value suggests that
the observed data or sample is
inconsistent with the Nal hypothesis
leading us to reject the Nile hypothesis
in favor of the alternative hypothesis a
large P value suggests that the observed
data is consistent with the null
hypothesis and we will not reject it
before I show you how to find a suitable
hypothesis test here is the important
last point there is always a risk of
making an error a small P value does not
prove that the altern itive hypothesis
is true it is only saying that it is
unlikely to get such a result or a more
extreme when the Nile hypothesis is true
and the other way around a large P value
does not prove that the null hypothesis
is true it is only saying that it is
likely to get such a result or a more
extreme when a n hypothesis is true so
there are two types of error which are
called type one and type two error let's
start with the type one error in
hypothesis testing a type one error
occurs when a true null hypothesis is
rejected so in reality the null
hypothesis is true but we make the
decision to reject the Nal hypothesis in
our example this means that the drug
actually did not work but our sample
happened to be so far off the true well
value that we mistakenly thought the
drug was working and a type two errow
occurs when a false hypothesis is not
rejected so in reality the null
hypothesis is false but we make the
decision to not reject an another
hypothesis in our example this means the
drag actually did work but it was just a
coincidence that the sample taken did
not show much difference and we
mistakenly thought the track was not
working and now I'll show you how data
helps you find a suitable hypothesis
test and of course calculates it and
interprets the results for you let's go
to data.net and copy your own data into
this table now the variables appear down
here data tab automatically tries to
determine the correct scale level but
you can also change it up here now just
click on hypo hthis testing and select
the variables on which we want to
calculate a hypothesis test data will
then suggest a test for example in this
case a Kai Square test or in that case
an analysis of variance then we will see
the
hypotheses and then the results if
you're not sure how to interpret the
results click on summary inverts further
you can check the assumptions and decide
whether you want want to calculate a
parametric or a non-parametric test you
can find out the difference between
parametric and nonparametric tests in my
next video thanks for watching and I
hope you enjoyed the video